[Musik]
damals entschieden zurückzutreten
zurückzutreten
das ist nun anders hecking tritt per
ende jahr aus dem zuger kantonsrat aus
ein schlussstrich kehrt nun ruhe ein und
die normalität zurück von ihrem ruf den
es wieder herzustellen gilt und ihrem
ruf nach anerkennung davon handelt
dieser film
als ich vor gut zwei jahren mit diesem
film hierbei yolanda spies hecking zu
hause begann liegt die verhängnisvolle
nacht knapp einen monat zurück bereits
jetzt vor den empörte kritiker ihren
rücktritt ja das ist natürlich schwierig
da der yuan aber ein nachspiel
was sind sie nur für einen track
[ __ ] sie gehen offen und wollen
nachher hüllemann klagen laufen anklagen
beides nicht passiert wegen
vergewaltigung wir werden alles
verfolgen und gnade ihnen gott sie
sollten sofort zurücktreten
das gab es ist wichtig das gibt's ja
jahrzehnte machen und mit aufgrund
probleme irgendwie irgendwie erfrischend
rücktrittsforderung es ist absurd -
ermöglicht gefordert ist etwas was mir
erwarte nicht was da passiert ist
was ist passiert ihre version der
geschehnisse an der zucker landammann
feier erzählt mir yolanda spies hegglin
am küchentisch von erinnerungslücken
flashbacks sexuellem missbrauch und ko
tropfen
ich habe es mir klar es ist möglich dass
ich mit dem philharmonia immer weiß
nicht ob ich kann mir vorstellen dass
man mit noch immer weiß was man macht
und und freiwillig also macht ihn
öffentlich nicht nur politische gegner
wie glücklich ich glaube nicht dass ich
nach meiner vereidigung im kantonsrat
das macht mir mehr opfer oder lügnerin
auf der verliererseite steht sie seit
jener nacht sowieso ob nun als opfer
einer nicht nachweisbaren tat oder aus
lügnerin die einen seitensprung zu
vertuschen versucht bewiesen ist bis
heute nichts
trotzdem hat die gesellschaft geurteilt
die lokalpolitikerin wird zur
zielscheibe hemmungsloser beschimpfungen
über den verstorbenen
mich erstaunt yolanda spiels hecklingen
liest solche kommentare nicht nur sie
antwortet auch was wiederum reaktionen
auslöst
nur wenn man auch in konzentrations
berater für personen nicht
die große bedürfnis
grad stellen und zeigen es möglich dass
die minister beschlossen
das ist schwierig
ja
die dreifache mutter holt ihren jüngsten
sohn von der kinderkrippe ab ein stück
normalität in dem urplötzlich aus den
fugen geratenen leben
der schritt in die öffentlichkeit ist
die verzweifelte versuch ordnung und
reputation wieder herzustellen
die familie bleibt lieber im hintergrund
im landtag verpasst wenn ich seine gut
also da muss man sich im moment bereitet
ob nun wahrheit oder lügenkonstrukt
tatsache ist yolanda spies hegglin steht
im fokus der öffentlichkeit das bekommen
auch die kinder mit mit dem ältesten
haben sie nach absprache mit der
schulpsychologin über das geschehene
gesprochen wird das überstehen
das betrifft die familien am nächsten
morgen sind yolanda spielen und ich
erneut verabredet
heute ist die erste kantonsratssitzung
seit der schicksalhaften nacht geplant
war dass ich sie dorthin begleiter doch
ihre kolleginnen und kollegen der zuger
grünen schirmen sie ab von den
parteikollegen flankiert marschiert
yolanda spies hecklingen richtung
regierungsgebäude noch demonstriert man
einigkeit schutz vor dem bereits auf sie
wartenden kameras
zweistellig
und wieder liegt der fraktion habe ich
unser klasse fans kräftig das
medieninteresse ist groß zum ersten mal
treffen die beiden akteure der
sogenannten zucker sex affäre wieder
aufeinander
der svp kantonsrat markus hörmann hat
heute morgen früh eine pressekonferenz
gegeben und von fremd küssen gesprochen
die untersuchung durch die zuger
staatsanwaltschaft bringt später ans
licht für limans dna wurden in spies
heckings vagina und unterhose gefunden
eine straftat ist damit dennoch nicht
bewiesen
von nun an bis zum ende des laufenden
verfahrens lautet hier niemand strategie
zweiten es wird ruhiger um ihn im
gegensatz zu spies hettling sie gibt
weiterhin interviews und intimitäten
preis doch heute hat ihr die partei
einen maulkorb verpasst ich sehe svp
regierungsrat heinz tännler auf seiner
feier aus neue zu galander mann ist es
zu dem vorfall gekommen
es ist gott im moment die bombardiert
wurden ist es ist in den tisch
seine vorkommen
ich weiß es ist das thema hier praktisch
jeder redet darüber
die wenigsten aber vor der kamera
[Musik]
max ist in einem thema nicht sagen wieso
die stadt seit ich 16
eigentlich gar nicht will mir halt
andere themen haben diese aber für sitte
heimat sein
eigentlich sind sie politisch
handlungsunfähig
die medienkrise und das ziemlich
entstanden ist dass politiker aus
alkohol in strömen geflossen ist an dem
fast nix gutes bild wo unfall kann man
sich vorstellt dass der kantonsrat mit
ko-tropfen also eine vierte stelle ich
werde jetzt erstmal ruhig geblieben wäre
hätte mich fern kalten und werden auch
wenn alles gesicht hätte ich mich daran
diese zum hof oder falsch zurück
nein
lohne
mit
tvs von aus
verschossen
sich aber nicht viel
für mich sind die politischen mit das
konto nicht verlernt zum gespött gemacht
während der pause bleibt yolanda spies
hecking im kantonsratssaal die fraktion
versucht sie weiterhin für uns
medienschaffenden abzuschaffen
sicherlich auch zum schutz der partei
die grünen politikerin soll nichts sagen
redet aber trotzdem
der fraktions chef weist sie in ihre
schranken
[Musik]
der rats betrieb an diesem morgen geht
weiter per sms teilten yolanda spies
hecking mit dass die fraktion auf sie
druck ausübe ich versuche es trotzdem
will mit ihr oder einem
fraktionsmitglied vor der kamera reden
fast scheint es als würden alle
vergessen wollen was geschehen ist bis
auf die eine die sagt sie könne sich an
nichts erinnern
juli an dass spies hegglin kämpft weiter
um ihren ruf
neun monate später treffen wir uns
wieder
es ist yolanda spies 135 geburtstag
in der zwischenzeit hat die zuger
staatsanwaltschaft die untersuchung
eingestellt weder medizinische proben
noch zeugenbefragungen haben bewiesen
dass yolanda spies hegglin in der
besagten nacht etwas gegen ihren willen
angetan wurde
in interviews und in den sozialen medien
verteidigt sie ihre version weiterhin ob
sie für nicht erfahrene gerechtigkeit
kämpft oder nur verzweifelt retten will
was ihr nach jener nacht geblieben ist
massenhaft hass kommentare sie ja
weiterhin gewiss aber so erzählt sie mir
hier auch zuspruch von ihrer fangemeinde
hunderte online freunde hätten wir heute
zum geburtstag gratuliert es stimmt dass
ein grund warum sie so aktiv sein wie
das gerät verbrauche der spruch das ist
also kann sich auch sicher dass ich dass
ich nicht das ist
es ist oder weil ich frage mich warum
sie immer postet warum sie so aktiv sich
der viel will ich mit provozieren zum
zum mmo wie man steuerlichen hat ganz
viele so wie ich die quoten sind diese
unterstützung fehlt hier im zuger
kantonsrat mittlerweile gänzlich der
letzte gut will scheint verloren
selbst die grünen wenden sich von ihrer
kollegin obwohl anders spielt er clean
ist unterdessen fraktionslos
das hat jetzt bietet wenig springen
die partie wurde dass sie die
kantonalparteien der sp cvp fdp und der
grünliberalen haben in einem offenen
brief ihren und hörmanns rücktritt
gefordert damit endlich ruhe ist ein
jahr nach ihrer vereidigung steht die
einstige hoffnungsträgerin der zuger
grünen komplett im abseits
sogar die eigene partei verlangt ein
ende des tages still zu sein scheint ihr
schwer zu fall und ich frage mich warum
was die schlechter beraten als er
jedenfalls sieht es nicht danach aus als
hätte ihr kommunikations eifer yolanda
spätling genugtuung verschafft auch sie
selbst will jetzt endlich ruhe
gemacht hat egal was passiert ich habe
gesprochen ich muss ich muss den ganzen
bekommen vor sagen dass die arbeit mit
zuwächsen
also alle jetzt dass sich ein bisschen
zurücknehmen aber dass die vielleicht
falsch kommuniziert
natürlich müsste betrachtet wenn wir die
situation ist denn das
aber wenn ich politiker und open source
und ich mir vor dem start war und ich
das mache was mich verteidigen aber das
ruinierte ruhe fordert die politische
karriere die ich jetzt in sand gesetzt
aber nichtsdestotrotz machen leute
ja will ich einfach selber mitbestimmen
was ich mache
ein wenig zu hoch dreht und ich hoffe
dass mir das
das ist das prinzip
die zeit drängt yolanda spies hecking
muss noch einkaufen unterwäsche diese
braucht sie für den bevorstehenden event
es ist soweit
im vorfeld hat die lokalpolitikerin
öffentlich auf facebook all ihre online
freunde zu ihrem geburtstag eingeladen
als dankeschön für die unterstützung
vermutlich war das ganze auch als
medienwirksame inszenierung geplant doch
der platz ist leer
in der dunkelheit findet sie ihren mann
reto
und endlich zwei gratulantinnen wenige
unterstützer aber umso mehr journalisten
[Musik]
nun fängt es auch noch zu regnen an auch
wenn sie sich nichts anmerken lässt die
veranstaltung fällt buchstäblich ins
wasser
wohl hat sie sich eine imagekorrektur
erhofft dabei aber wieder
negativschlagzeilen generiert
ungeschickt selbstverschuldet jedenfalls
ihr aufruf auf facebook war für jeden
einsehbar
ein paar online freunde kommen dann doch
noch und sie bringen wie von yolanda
spies hecking gewünscht neu gekaufte
damenwäsche mit als zeichen gegen
sexuellen missbrauch
die höschen werden später der caritas
gespendet für ihre fangemeinde bleibt
sie das starke opfer das sich von den
bulgaren hass tierarten nicht
unterkriegen lässt
das verletzt mich ist das moralische
empfinden sehr stark dass man ein mann
im heads up and read so verliert so
verdammt ermittelt aus der wirklich das
sind kommentare da hat man schon
losgehen da ist muss mit
mehrmals in diesem jahr habe ich
vergeblich versucht ihren mann zu
interviewen
jetzt sehe ich eine chance ihre fragen
hat mir gesagt dass sie sind
die maus ist einfach für sie
durch dumme ist es bleibt bei einem nein
reto spies steht zu seiner frau möchte
sie unterstützen nicht aber in der
öffentlichkeit ein jahr nach der
folgenschweren länder man feiere wirkt
yolanda spies hegglin abgekämpft und
müde
es vergeht ein weiteres jahr ihre
präsenz in der presse und in radio und
fernsehen ist geringer geworden
in den sozialen medien aber dreht sich
die geschichte weiter
als ich mich im oktober dieses jahres
erneut auf den weg nach zug mache ist es
ruhiger geworden
markus hörmann ist längst kein thema
mehr
und auch yolanda spies hegglin scheint
sich gefunden zu haben und konzentriert
sich auf dinge die sie selber
beeinflussen kann
sie zeigt die verfasser widerliche hass
kommentare unterdessen auch an
ich treffe mich mit ihr und irina
studhalter von den jungen grünen
beide frauen wurden im netz aufs übelste
beschimpft darunter waren auch
morddrohungen in irina studhalter fall
war der auslöser ein tweet zur
islamhetze wie sie es nannte aufgrund
ihrer erfahrungen wollen die beiden nun
einen verein gründen und anderen
shitstorm betroffenen helfen die
ambulanz und es geht darum dass wenn sie
internet sachen vorkommen cybermobbing
oder so dass man aus verein eine
anlaufstelle ist wo man kann man haben
unterstützung bekommt beraterbüro wenn
wir nicht studierten löscht man das so
aber hat noch katharina das ist ein
hobby steht das muss noch als dass man
die wissenschaft sieht noch erleben und
ich habe erreicht dass klar dass das
nicht das was sie auch aus die
veranstalter seien realisiert dass das
nur vom [ __ ] oder als nur musik
frank rost zum beispiel
sie hat gemerkt dass ich mir das nicht
wirklich
sie wollte den zeitpunkt stets selber
bestimmen nun ist er da so landers spies
hegglin tritt per ende jahr als
kantonsrätin zurück vielleicht ist es
der schlussstrich unter eine
politkarriere die über nacht scheiterte
bevor sie richtig begonnen hatte
vielleicht aber ist es der neubeginn
einer frau die seit zwei jahren mit
allen mitteln versucht ihren guten ruf
wieder herzustellen
aber ob nun tatsächlich ruhe eintritt
ist eine schule in gesellschaft mit
stellte der geworden
[Musik]